l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
gouvernement la parole est à madame
emilie cariou ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le garde des sceaux ministre de
la justice monsieur le ministre le
parquet national financier est né à
l'issue d'une grave crise politico
financière en 2013 et a été créé pour
répondre à la nécessité d'améliorer la
réponse pénale face à la délinquance
financière
le pnf et l'indépendance de ses membres
constitue une réponse au sentiment
d'impunité ressentie par les français
face aux manquements à la probité au
confit d'intérêt et aux violations les
plus graves des grecs et économique dans
notre pays
il a rapidement déployé ses moyens et ce
parquet spécialisé a établi sa
réputation à l'échelon international
avec tous les services chargés de la
lutte contre la fraude dont la bnrdf
c'est l'édifice de tout un travail que
je salue ici en octobre 2018 lors de
l'adoption de la loi relative à la lutte
contre la fraude
votre majorité dans cette assemblée a
amplifié sa mission nous avons alors
renforcer les pouvoirs des parcs et dont
le pnf avec l'ouverture du verrou de
bercy et de nouveaux outils juridiques
données pour les juridictions
financières telles que la cgil et la
crpc
ces apports mon corps était salué la
semaine dernière en commission des
finances à l'occasion d'un rapport que
j'ai vendu avec eric diard député les
républicains allaient plus vite et plus
fort tout en replaçant l'indépendance
des pouvoirs au coeur du dispositif
c'est ce qui constitue l'armature de ce
parc est devenu un navire amiral de
notre action publique contre la
délinquance financière
monsieur le garde des sceaux votre
prédécesseur à diligenter une inspection
sur le pnf le rapport de l'inspection
générale de la justice fait état d'un
bon bilan technique du bnf et de
l'absence de manquement formel
or vous avez annoncé vendredi dernier le
lancement d'une enquête administrative
sur deux membres actuels du bnf et sur
madame eliane houlette ancien procureur
national du parc national financiers
aujourd'hui votre été
monsieur le ministre ma question est
très simple quelles réponses faites vous
aujourd'hui au conseil supérieur de la
magistrature qui exceptionnellement a
exprimé sa préoccupation sur ces
enquêtes administratives supplémentaires
que vous avez un nom
et sur l'un des ponts la garantie de
l'indépendance de l'autorité judiciaire
la parole est à monsieur eric
dupond-moretti garde des sceaux ministre
de la justice
je vous demande de regagner vos places
en silence pour faire en sorte que tout
le monde puisse bien entendre les
questions et bien longtemps les réponses
et à l'avenir va arriver à l'heure moi
ce pays vous avez la parole monsieur le
ministre
[Applaudissements]
non
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît monsieur
le ministre à la parole et lui seul
madame monsieur le président madame
madame la députée carew mesdames et
messieurs les députés
merci de me poser cette question des
journalistes ça et là me l'ont déjà posé
et c'est devant la représentation
nationale que j'entends évidemment
apporter la réponse la plus complète
permettez-moi d'abord de répondre par la
chronologie tant il est vrai que la
chronologie n'est pas sujette à
subjectivité
premièrement c'est madame nicole
belloubet qui a ordonné l'inspection des
services
elle a exprimé l'idée que ce qui s'était
passé était choquant ce sont les mots
qu'elle a utilisés il s'agissait d'une
enquête secrète qui a duré six ans on a
fouillé les fadettes de magistrats
d'avocats et d'une journaliste
le syndicat de les syndicats de
magistrats ont alors poussé des cris
d'orfraie et ils ont tenté de faire dire
au conseil d'état que cette inspection
était illégale le conseil d'état a
répondu que cette inspection était
parfaitement légal
un syndicat de magistrats a alors
indiqué que le conseil d'état avait
rendu une décision tout à fait
singulière et qu'il était désormais
détachée d'un certain nombre de 2 qu'il
ne s'intéressait plus à la liberté
on s'autorise tout parfois madame et
puis la formule exacte c'est le conseil
d'état a abdiqué a écrit le syndicat de
la magistrature
et puis le rapport a été rendu je n'y ai
participé ni de près ni de loin j'ai dit
je rendrai public et je les rangs du
public
et puis mes services ont été saisis je
n'ai pas tenu leurs plumes
ils ont dit qu éventuellement il y avait
un certain nombre de dysfonctionnements
qui tenait à la fois un manque de
diligence un manque de rigueur un manque
de loyauté
qu'auriez-vous fait madame la députée à
ma place il était normal
bien évidemment il était normal que nous
allions que nous avions
[Applaudissements]
il
que des magistrats qui ne veulent pas
répondre à l'inspection des services et
préfère répondre à paris match ça me
chagrine
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à monsieur julien dive
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur premier ministre la semaine
dernière le groupe japonais bridgestone
a annoncé la fermeture de son usine de
pneus de béthune dans les hautes france
8 163 salariés en cdi sont menacés par
cette annonce ainsi qu'une centaine de
sous-traitants
c'est un carnage sociale cette casse
sociale n'est que l'énième exemple de la
désindustrialisation dangereuse de notre
pays en effet en france certains groupes
au nom d'une logique économique plus
douteuses n'hésitent désormais plus à
s'essuyer les pieds sur les vies de
milliers de salariés et leurs familles
en pensant que du jour au lendemain on
peut prendre les aides financières et
partir il est temps de siffler la fin de
la récréation
la crise sanitaire n'excuse pas tout
plusieurs groupes dont bridgestone
compte utiliser ce contexte sanitaire
pour justifier des destructions
d'emplois alors même qu'il prévoyait
cette opération depuis plusieurs mois
c'est tout simplement inacceptable
le président de la région des hautes
france a été le premier à réagir à
exiger d'autres alternatives à la
décision de bridgestone
êtes vous sincèrement décidé à emboîter
le pas devant la menace de suppression
de ces milliers d'emplois nous devons
tous nous réunir à dépendamment de nos
différends politiques pour engager un
véritable bras de fer est allée plus
loin sur la loi florange monsieur le
premier ministre
êtes vous prêt à aller plus loin à
interroger notre modèle de soutien
économique et exiger des gages à ces
groupes lorsqu'un site ferme sans autre
raison que leurs intérêts financiers ou
pour une délocalisation organisé depuis
bridgestone a touché plus de 4 millions
4 d'euros dette publique
êtes vous prêts à nous présenter une loi
plus coercitives et obliger à rembourser
toute aide comme le cic eux
monsieur le premier ministre la crise
sanitaire eu un impact pour l'économie
et nos entreprises c'est indéniable
néanmoins l'ensemble des acteurs publics
sont là pour aider ces groupes les
accompagner trouver des solutions face à
cela nous ne pouvons pas accepter des
méthodes qui met en péril la vie de
milliers de salariés
on ne peut pas vouloir la
réindustrialisation de notre pays et le
maintien des emplois sans faire
comprendre à ces groupes qui si en
france le diptyque on prend l'argent et
on cyr ne marche pas
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
madame agnès pannier vue nash ministre
délégué chargé de l'industrie merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député dit d'abord merci de
remarquer la rapidité avec laquelle le
président de la région de france et
l'état puisque cette réaction elle a été
portée par un communiqué de presse
commun qui montre le plat alignement sur
ce dossier des élus locaux et de l'état
et l'engagement que nous avons de l'est
répondre à ces 8 163 salariés dont je
salue la dignité dans ce moment
difficile et auxquels je veux dire
l'engagement plein et entier de l'état
pour les accompagner et je rappelle
qu'il était déjà présent et à l'année
dernière et il ya deux ans quand les
premières discussions ont eu lieu
je veux également revenir sur la
stratégie que nous avons en matière
industrielle parce que vous parlez
effectivement de cette politique
industrielle qui a détruit de l'emploi
entre 2008 et 2018 et vous avez raison
de le souligner et c'est bien pour ça
que ce gouvernement depuis trois ans a
pris à bras le corps ce sujet de
l'industrie et à la différence des deux
mandatures précédentes à recréer de
l'emploi industriel de l'emploi
industriel net sur l'ensemble des
territoires
et c'est dans cette direction que nous
allons continuer à travailler
monsieur le député travailler en étant
capable de trouver des solutions pour
des entreprises comme arc comme condat
comme en bar par exemple mais également
des solutions d'entreprise qui
s'installe en france et je veux citer
ici l'exemple de l'entreprise
industrielle qui va bâtir construire les
batteries électriques grâce au
gouvernement français 2400 emplois à
douvrin de création voilà le type de
politique industrielle dont nous avons
envie
et aux côtés de groupes qui s'engage qui
créent de l'emploi et qui innovent
je vous remercie merci madame la
ministre la parole est à monsieur adrien
cnas monsieur le premier ministre john
est un scandale et derrière l'arbre
bridgestone se cache la forêt auchan
car guil acfa verallia et toutes les
autres que ces deux minutes ne me
suffirait pas à citer mais que vous
retrouverez répertoriées sur le site
internet stop licenciements point fr
l'état s'est rendu complice de ce
massacre social en gavant d'argent
public sans vision et sans contre partie
des groupes qui n'ont fait qu'ils n'ont
que faire de l'intérêt général mais ne
se soucie que des profits de leurs
actionnaires
lorsque françois hollande créé le sehy
ce que vous avez pérenniser en baisse de
cotisations on entendait monsieur gattaz
du medef promettre partout un million
d'emplois
le bilan est désormais connue c'est
plutôt un million d'euros par emploi le
cic eux ayant à peine créé une centaine
de milliers d'emplois est votre plan de
relance salué à son tour par le medef ne
vise rien d'autre que cela catapulter
des milliards et encore des milliards
sans cohérence sans stratégie et sans
contrepartie assez d'hypocrisie
l'état va-t-il refusé l'homologation du
plan de licenciements prévus par
bridgestone
allez vous enfin exigé dans la loi des
contreparties ou le remboursement des
aides versées à ces grandes entreprises
monsieur macro on nous a bassiné matin
midi et soir avec l'europe qui protège
or dans cette affaire votre europe qui
protège c'est l'europe qui détruit et
qui organise la compétition déloyale
entre les états membres
votre europe qui protège c'est celle qui
à subventionner l'installation de
bridgestone en pologne pendant que le
groupe abandonné le site français de
béthune votre europe qui protège c'est
celle qui refuse l'harmonisation sociale
pour exacerber la compétition
généralisés sur les prix et ainsi
détruire petit à petit ce qu'il aura
fallu des décennies pour bâtir la france
n'est pas une salle de jeux ni un casino
combien de temps allons nous rester les
bras ballants sans protection face à ces
situations
monsieur le premier ministre la
planification au commence quand merci
monsieur député la parole à madame agnès
pannier relâché ministre délégué chargé
de l'industrie merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député qu'internet
permet de souligner l'action du
gouvernement pour l'emploi puisque si
nous prenons les chiffres factuellement
c'est ce gouvernement qui a créé cinq
cent mille emplois en 2010 est un 2018
et en 2019 pourquoi cinq cent mille
emplois parce que nous avons une
conviction chevillée au corps c'est que
le travail est l'acte fondateur de la
dignité et le meilleure arme pour lutter
contre la pauvreté et c'est en ce sens
que nous avons construit toute notre
action politique alors sans doute loin
des idéologies qui enferme qui normes et
qui empêche justement ces créations
d'emplois sur les territoires et moi je
veux vous dire monsieur k ternas que je
vous tends la main pour trouver des
solutions sur ces emploi cje entreprises
en difficulté qu'a vous parler de
l'europe mais qui est allée auprès de
l'europe pour mettre en place des
mesures de sauvegarde sur les pneus
lourd qui est à lille auprès de l'europe
pour mettre en place des mesures de
sauvegarde sur l'acier qui a négocié
auprès de l'europe un accord qui permet
de disposer historiquement de 750
milliards d'euros pour faire la relance
de notre économie
aujourd'hui se bat pour décarbonés notre
industrie pour la moderniser en mettant
35 milliards d'euros
pas l'un sans contrepartie mais pour les
pme pour les entreprises de taille
intermédiaire car ce sont les
principales bénéficiaires de notre plan
celles qui créent de l'emploi sur les
territoires et celles qui aujourd'hui
sont capable justement de répondre aux
problèmes d'emploi auxquels nous faisons
face
alors s'il vous plaît soyons
pragmatiques monsieur carnage et faisons
en sorte d'aller défendre chaque emploi
ensemble avec des solutions
industrielles et pas des gros mots
la parole à monsieur francis choix
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur le ministre se
retrouver expulsées de son dernier
espace de quiétude
en plein procès des attentats de 2015
c'est lourd à porter c'est très violent
mais c'est surtout un signal qui devrait
nous alerter sur le désastre en cours
cette citation de la sente jeu
l'empreinte à une femme que la
représentation nationale s'honorerait à
saluer comme d'ailleurs toutes les
victimes de harcèlement terrorisant
cette femme c'est malika bret à la
directrice des ressources humaines de
charlie hebdo ce journal et ses
personnels qui sont de nouveau la cible
d'attaqués ignoble d'antisémite dix
novices qui défigure la religion de
millions de musulmans pacifiques et ceux
pour qui la france devrait vivre sous la
loi d'une sorte de sharjah et du
blasphème
elle n'est pas critiquer mallet cabrette
elle n'est pas insulter elle est menacée
menacé de mort oui de mort au point que
sa protection policière sous laquelle
elle vit depuis cinq ans l'a enjointe de
quitter son domicile
en moins de dix minutes monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur fasse un tel
déchaînement il ne faut pas procrastiner
au prétexte de ne pas fâché de ne pas
stigmatiser de ne pas en rajouter comme
de l'ach bonnes âmes nous y invite
il faut la protéger vous le faites
il faut agir pour le pet
mais il faut nommer le mal oui oui je
stigmatise les terroristes de la peur et
leurs complices adepte d'un funeste
relativisme de la république
soyons tous debout avec malika bret avec
charlie toujours la france le vivra
jamais sous le règne sur le règne de la
terreur islamiste merci
[Musique]
la parole la parole à monsieur gérald
darmanin ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
francis choix je n'ai pas grand chose à
rajouter à votre réquisitoire pour la
liberté pour la protection de nos
valeurs pour la république pour saluer
le courage de tous ceux qui à charlie
hebdo et ailleurs au sacrifice de leur
liberté répondent et redisent à quel
point la grandeur de la france c'est
évidemment de pouvoir caricature est
évidemment de pouvoir choquer évidemment
de pouvoir imprimer évidemment de
pouvoir dessiner et de pouvoir le dire
et le redire et l'assemblée nationale
par votre voix sonore monsieur le député
si je peux me permettre
du courage de vos propos
madame la directrice des ressources
humaines de charlie hebdo depuis cinq
ans vous l'avait dit et sur décision de
mes prédécesseurs et protégé par la
république c'est bien ce qu'on lui doit
mais en ce moment un moment même où les
procès qui démontre les actes ignobles
qui ont été commis sur le sol de la
république sans pouvoir donner plus de
détails sur la protection des personnels
des magistrats de tous ceux qui
concourent à l'objectivation de la
vérité je peux vous assuré monsieur le
député que c'est des dizaines et des
dizaines de policiers qui protègent ces
personnes qui sont aujourd'hui gravement
menacé j'ai donc demandé à la lecture
des faits que vous évoquez d'abord
qu'une protection puissent être
évidemment bien réaffirmer pour
l'ensemble du personnel de charlie hebdo
j'ai moi même appelé le directeur de la
publication pour l'assurer bien sûr du
soutien du gouvernement à la demande du
premier ministre
mais pour lui assurer de la sécurité de
la république j'ai aussi demandé que
nous puissions sans complaisance
poursuivre et 100 mais sans conditions
sans 600 rien avant la phrase mais tous
ceux qui font l'apologie du terrorisme
tout ce qui justifie la justiciables et
tout ce qui conditionne leur soutien à
des actes de menaces de mort qu'il soit
sur les journalistes sur les
parlementaires sur les élus et surtout
les citoyens de la république
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur david habib
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre la semaine passée notre
collègue alain david vous interpeller
sur l'évolution de la pandémie
l'augmentation des cas positifs et des
hospitalisations
votre réponse des concentrations et
territoires monsieur le premier ministre
au pire c'est de l' esquive au mieux un
hors sujet se défausser sur le local
n'est pas l'enjeu que matt ont demandé
ces derniers jours je suis qu'à
contacter mais je n'ai pas été appelé
par l'assurance maladie
ai-je droit un arrêt de travail la
classe de mon enfant ferme
je ne peux pas télétravail et quelles
solutions étudiante dans un amphithéâtre
bondé
comment respecter les gestes barrière
votre communication monsieur le premier
ministre est incertaine et les délais de
traitement dissuade les français de se
faire tester et surtout de s'isoler
l'heure est grave monsieur le premier
ministre vous devez répondre français
chaque jour des milliers de cas déclarés
vous êtes en train de perdre les
français plus particulièrement les plus
jeunes parce qu'il ya trop de
contradictions trop d'erreurs trop de
zones d'ombrés dans votre discours
nous socialistes dès le début nous avons
choisi de ne pas faire de la crise
sanitaire un enjeu partisan
il s'agit de la santé des français mais
notre responsabilité monsieur
prémunissent c'est de vous dire ce qui
ne marche pas faute de temps je
n'aborderai que 2.1 le dépistage
hier le ministre de la santé a annoncé
24 heures d'attentes pour les publics
prioritaires mais combien d'attentes
pour le reste des français
si tous les salariés d'une petite
entreprise doivent attendre leur
résultat pendant sept jours
monsieur le premier ministre cette
entreprise elle coule la grippe
il sera difficile de faire face au co
vide et concomitamment à la grippe
saisonnière
quel est donc votre stratégie pour
favoriser la vaccination la plus massive
possible auprès de tous les publics quel
que soit leur âge
on nous dit qu'on aura une réponse en
octobre non la volonté politique c'est
d'afficher l'ambition de votre
gouvernement dès aujourd'hui
merci chers collègues la parole à
monsieur olivier verront ministre des
solidarités de la santé monsieur le
député david habib merci pour vos
multiples questions auxquelles je ne
pourrais pas répondre maintenant
l'espace de deux minutes même si j'ai
peu avoir un débit de mitraillette quand
il m'en prends l'envi et vous
comprendrez aisément pourquoi ce que je
voudrais vous dire c'est que vous
soulignez vous soulignez à juste titre
que l'épidémie a pris de l'ampleur dans
notre pays ces dernières semaines
ce que je me suis chine et comme
d'autres à rappeler aux français y
compris pendant la période estivale
lorsque le relâchement et est devenue la
règle
la stratégie du gouvernement monsieur
habib elle n'a pas changé des mesures
différencier territoire par territoire
concertée localement lorsque les mesures
ont pu être décidée depuis paris est
annoncé depuis paris
nous avions le procès en centrisme
parisien déconnecté des territoires dès
lors que nous confions aux préfets le
soin de consulter de concerter de
prendre 48 72 heures pour déterminer les
bonnes dispositions vous nous accusez
presque de nous des fausses et de nos
responsabilités
ni l'une ni l'autre monsieur le député
habib les mesures qui sont prises sont
prises en fonction de la situation
sanitaire propres à chaque territoire
parce que la situation sanitaire dans
les bouches du rhône et en particulier à
marseille n'est pas la même que celle du
coeur de la dordogne et cette
différenciation qui de mieux que les
préfets et que les élus des
collectivités territoriales pour pouvoir
l'appréhender et prendre les mesures qui
s'imposent vous avez posé des questions
sur la filière des tests monsieur le
député et rappelé qu' hier oui hier
j'étais à mantes la jolie pour inaugurer
l'un des vins barnum capables chacun de
réaliser 50 est par jour déployé en
ile-de-france de manière à ce que les
publics prioritaires les patients
symptomatiques les cas contactez les
soignants les intervenants du domicile
puissent avoir un résultat plus rapide
que les autres monsieur députés
voulaient poser beaucoup de questions
que je pourrai répondre factuellement je
vous en donner une de réponse par
exemple quand vous me dites que
quelqu'un est en attente de son test
pour savoir s'il peut retourner au
travail
monsieur le député ou illescas contact
auquel cas il doit rester chez lui
pendant sept jours et avoir fait un test
négatif à sept jours pour retourner au
travail où il est symptomatique et il
doit rester
chez lui jusqu'à ce que le tester et
démontrer le contraire ou alors rien ne
l'empêchent d'aller au travail
ne mettons pas non plus de la confusion
par les interrogations que nous posons
sur un sujet qui est déjà complexe à
appréhender la parole que madame
marguerite deprez audebert ma question
s'adresse à madame agnès pannier rue
nash et bridgestone béthune
on croyait ces deux noms liés à vie tant
lusine faisait partie du patrimoine
béthunois à l'image de son beffroi
elle fut en 1961 grâce à l'action de la
jeune chambre économique
un cadeau venu du ciel américains
incarnant la mort de la reconversion
minière mais tu n'étais alors au coeur
du marché de l'europe du nord-ouest
lusine a fait vivre jusque j'ai connu
cinq cents familles on y travaillait de
père en fils et on a été fier avec le
nouveau siècle elle est passée sous
bannière japonaise si vers l'est et le
sud que se sont déplacés les marchés
mais aussi la compétitivité la pologne
et l'italie ont bénéficié des
investissements dont l' usine de béthune
aurait eu besoin pour se restructurer et
se robotisés il y a quelques années en
france pendant ces décennies nous avons
maintenu voire accrues une fiscalité
dissuasive en taxant lourdement une
production facilement délocalisables 6
millions d'euros de contribution en 2002
en 2019 pour le site de béthune se le
doit cela doit interroger notre
responsabilité collective d'élus la
rentabilité n'a donc fait que décroître
avec un marché mondial baissier une
absence de politique industrielle
européenne
une consommation s'adapte à notre
stratégie de mobilité partagée et la
chute de rentabilité du groupe nippon
le couperet est tombé le 16 septembre
bridgestone ne veux pas profiter des
mesures prises par le gouvernement pour
réenchanter l'industrie relancer
l'économie et relocaliser de la
production avec plus de 2000 familles
touchées c'est tout un territoire qui
sera lourdement impactés madame bornes
et vous mais madame la nuit c'est étiez
hier à béthune
accompagnés des services de l'état vous
les avez
élus mobilisés syndicats enclin au
dialogue salariés digne mais désabusé et
attristé c'est avance un point qu'il
faudra apporter une réponse
je sais que le gouvernement ne laissera
pas tomber le béthunois dont l'adn est
industriel et qui doit rester un
territoire d'industrie la parole à
madame agnès pannier relâché ministre
délégué chargé de l'industrie mesdames
et messieurs les députés monsieur le
président madame la députée marguerite
deprez audebert merci d'abord d'avoir
été présentés hier et d'avoir marqué
depuis ces quelques jours votre entière
disponibilité pour nous accompagner et
nous aider à trouver une solution pour
cette usine de béthune que vous
connaissez si bien puisque c'est votre
père qui avait réussi à l'installer dans
le béthunois
alors qu'elle était en compétition avec
une autre région et je rappeler ce ce
fait je sais que vous êtes côtés des
salariés des huit cent soixante trois
familles qui aujourd'hui sont inquiets
pour leur avenir et je sais que vous
ferez tout comme les élus locaux comme
le président de région et comme les
services de l'état pour trouver une
solution afin de donner un avenir à
chacun des salariés et de devenez un
avenir à ce site nous savons à quel
point le béthunois et l'avenir de
béthune est attaché à l'industrie alors
comme vous le savez nous n'avons pas
traîné mercredi annonce de la fermeture
ou en tout cas de ce projet vendredi
signature d'un accord de méthode qui a
repris toutes les demandes des
organisations syndicales donnant du
temps à une négociation de qualité pour
trouver des alternatives lundi réunion
où nous avons évoqué la réouverture de
scénarios alternatifs et nous nous
battons un cabinet pour faire la contre
expertise
des chiffres qui nous seront données par
la société bridgestone et nous
analyserons des scénarios permettant de
maintenir de l'activité à bridgestone
mais également de prendre en compte la
situation du béthunois et la situation
des sous-traitants
car il ne faudrait pas qu'il soit oublié
dans cette opération
nous avons cinq mois 5 pas pour analyse
avec elizabeth bornes les compétences
des salariés et leur donner de la
visibilité sur la vers leur avenir cinq
mois pour densifier ce test sites
industriels ou malheureusement la
production est aujourd'hui très
largement inférieure est celle qu'elle a
été il ya une dizaine d'années cinq mois
pour également trouver des solutions
alternatives
la parole qu'à venir gêner duby muller
monsieur le premier ministre en février
dernier avec mon collègue olivier marc
l'ex nous avions déjà interpellé le
ministre de l'économie sur la crise de
gouvernance chez angie dénonçant un
probable plan caché du gouvernement
malheureusement nous avions vu juste
avec l'offensive hostile de veolia pour
démanteler suez
votre gouvernement nous avait répondu la
main sur le coeur que l'état exercera sa
responsabilité vis-à-vis d'énergie
monsieur le premier ministre permettez
nous d'en douter
nous dénonçons au contraire votre
légèreté coupable sur les dossiers
industriels en acceptant la casse
sociale d'un fleuron français avec une
prévision de 10 mille emplois supprimés
et ce au moment même où notre pays
traverse une crise économique sans
précédent
cette légèreté coupable vous pousse
aussi à priver les collectivités
territoriales d'une saine concurrence
entre deux champions français
chacun comprend bien qu à la place des
synergies locales affichée par veolia la
réalité sera beaucoup plus brutale elle
aura pour nom fermetures de sites
industriels et destructions d'emplois
dans les agences territoriales comme en
haute savoie le risque direct d'une
telle manoeuvre c'est évidemment une
forte augmentation de la facture d'eau
pour les français alors même que leur
pouvoir d'achat est déjà très lourdement
impacté d'autant plus sensée dans les
activités au fond meridiam qui n'offrent
aucune garantie pour les 9000 salariés
de cette branche est qui n'est pas un
spécialiste de l'eau monsieur le premier
ministre les français ne supportent plus
d'être otage des mercato financier du
président de la république après ses
échecs sur alstom et alcatel
évitons un énième dépeçage industriels
soutenus par emmanuel macron car il
s'agirait bien de comprendre qu on ne
fusionne pas des machines mais bien des
femmes et des hommes et des relations
historiques avec les élus ma question
est donc la même qu'en février dernier
nous vous demandons de clarifier vos
attentions et d'agir en pleine lumière
plutôt que dans les secrets des couloirs
merci merci madame le député la parole
est à madame olivia grégoire secrétaire
d'état chargée de l'économie sociale
solidaire et responsable
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président madame messieurs
les députés
madame la députée virginie duby muller
quelle légèreté coupable veolia a fait
savoir son intention et vous le savez de
racheter à angie près de 30% de suez et
à formuler une offre à cette fin l'état
examinera de fait en tant qu'actionnaire
d' angie et dans le cadre de la
gouvernance de l'entreprise cette offre
mais aussi les autres offres qui
pourraient être amenés à être présenté
dans les prochains jours avec la plus
grande impartialité et sur la base des
engagements fermes que l'acheteur veolia
ou d'autres devra présenter le
gouvernement n'a jamais absolument
jamais dévier de cette position ainsi si
une offre est présentée prochainement
nous nous donnerons le temps de
l'examiner avec la plus grande rigueur
le gouvernement sera particulièrement
vigilant vigilant dans ce processus à ce
que l'offre retenue respectent un
certain nombre de critères premier
critère la pérennité de l'emploi d'abord
et alors vous l'avez rappelé madame duby
muller que nous traversons une crise
économique sans pareil pérennité de
l'emploi alors que les salariés de suez
faut-il le rappeler notamment les plus
de trente mille femmes et hommes
employés en france qui ont été en
première ligne durant l'épidémie du code
vide que ce soit en matière de
traitement des déchets comme en matière
de gestion de l'accès à l'eau suez est
incontestablement un de nos fleurons
industriels fort de compétences pointues
nous souhaitons le préserver ainsi
préservé un ancrage territorial fort
la logique industrielle ensuite
notamment en s'assurant que les acteurs
susceptibles de reprendre les activités
de suez en france soit et crédible et
robuste et engager à long terme il n'est
pas question que cette opération soit le
prélude d'une perte de souveraineté dans
des secteurs aussi sensibles et
stratégiques
madame duby muller je vous le garantis
impartialité neutralité et efficacité
et de l'état sur ce dossier sans si
madame la ministre la parole est à
monsieur vincent ledoux est à lui seul
est un peu moins de bruit si le monsieur
le président connaissez la réplique du
théâtre de perrault anne ma soeur anne
ne vois-tu rien venir
alors nous sommes un peu au groupe agir
ensemble désespéré de ne voit rien venir
monsieur le ministre des comptes publics
sur deux choses la première c'est sur
l'aide promise à la filière des pommes
de terre puisque vous savez que la crise
qu'ovide les a frappés de plein fouet
que 200 mille tonnes ont été dégagées
vers une consommation qui était non
alimentaire est valorisé mais ils
doivent transformer leur outil de
production vers un label environnemental
deuxième chose monsieur le ministre des
comptes publics
c'est l'amendement proposé par monsieur
dharmanand hop élèves 2020 et qui doté
de 10 millions d'euros un fonds
sécheresse qui permettait d'indemniser
les familles de victimes de cet
retrait-gonflement des argiles dans
toute la france et qui permettait
notamment d'aider ceux qui échappent et
à la reconnaissance en catastrophe
naturelle c'est très important parce que
je vais vous dire qu'aujourd'hui il y à
des sinistrés qui depuis un an doivent
louer au milieu des habitations sans
être indemnisées donc c'est une double
peine mais aussi des gens je pensais aux
dunkerquois vivent aujourd'hui dans des
caravanes
donc c'est une situation totalement
indigne et nous avons besoin aujourd'hui
que la parole de l'état soit crédible et
soient traduites de manière concrète sur
le terrain donc la question est assez
simple
quid des 10 millions d'euros pour le
fonds aux sécheresses et quid des 10
millions d'euros qui seront qui
devraient être alloués à l'aide à la
filière des pommes de terre je vous
remercie
la parole est à monsieur olivier dussopt
pts ministre des comptes publics
merci à monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les députés monsieur le
député le doubs deux questions de
réponse concernant la filière pomme de
terre que vous avez évoqué des travaux
sont encore en cours avec julien de
normandie ministre de l'agriculture cela
prend quelques temps le calage notamment
avec les règles communautaires mais vous
devriez voir venir pour reprendre votre
expression très rapidement des solutions
sur le sujet deuxième question deuxième
réponse concernant le décret relatif à
l'argile notamment à la sécheresse
créditeurs et des hydrates à sion pardon
de 2018 vous avez rappelé à juste titre
que cette catastrophe naturelle n'avait
pu être reconnus comme tels du fait de
ses particularités et vous avez souligné
la situation extrêmement précaire de
propriétaires de logements utilisé à
usage d'habitation principale souvent
touchés dans leur structure et qui
peuvent être même inhabitable vous avez
voté et vous avez rappelé que c'était un
amendement du gouvernement porté par
gérald darmanin un fonds de 10 millions
d'euros ce fonds est sanctuarisée nous
travaillons actuellement avec emmanuelle
wargon ministre du logement pour la
rédaction du décret
ce décret doit tenir compte comme vous
l'aviez souhaité du niveau de revenu de
visages de l'habitation à titre de
résidence principale et de
l'articulation de ces aides avec les
aides de l'anah
le décret sera publié avant le début du
débat sur le plf donc avant la mi
octobre
et j'ajoute que madame barbara pompili
et madame emmanuelle wargon ont signé en
juillet dernier un arrêté pour garantir
qu'ils aient des études de préventive
sur les télés terrain où il ya des
allergies le définit de manière à éviter
que cette situation se reproduise
vous aurez sur votre territoire comme
sur les autres territoires sinistrés
les 10 millions vous avez voté merci
monsieur le ministre la parole s'il vous
plaît la parole à madame josette manin
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur sébastien lecornu
ministre les outre-mer monsieur le
ministre
depuis ces derniers mois la martinique
est secoué par de multiples
manifestations et actes de violence
qu'il renvoie aux blessures mal
cicatrisées de notre histoire commune
l'esclavagé la colonisation
pour beaucoup de ces manifestants l'état
perpétue encore une forme de violence
symbolique et structurelles vis-à-vis
des antilles françaises
toutefois la martinique fait partie
intégrante de la république elle entend
le rester mais en dehors des questions
historiques c'est le dossier de la
chlordécone qui est le sujet central des
revendications de la population pour
rappel une commission d enquête
parlementaire a permis de comprendre et
de découvrir les raisons et les
responsabilités liées à l'utilisation de
ce poison à l'époque à formuler 42
propositions pour engager le processus
de réparation des préjudices économiques
sanitaires et agricoles induits à ce
jour nous restons en attente de leur
mise en place malgré les promesses du
président de la république le 27
septembre 2018 d'aller vers la
réparation
bien évidemment le plan de relance met
en avant un accompagnement pour la
transformation agricole et l'objectif de
souveraineté alimentaire d'ici 2030
en attendant le territoire se meurt les
cancers se multiplient les agriculteurs
qui ont manipulé ce poison pendant ces
longues années de tolérance agonise
lentement nos bébés naissent avec des
malformations
il est urgent et vital que la loi-cadre
puisse être appliquée afin qu'aucun
doute ne subsiste sur les intentions de
l'état monsieur le ministre quel sera
votre force d'action pour que l'état
tienne définitivement ses engagements
envers les territoires de la guadeloupe
de la martinique
merci merci chers collègues la parole
est à monsieur sébastien le corps du
ministre d outre-mer merci monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les députés
madame la députée josette manin le
dossier de la chlordécone est un dossier
grave un scandale ça a été rappelé par
le président de la république il est
maintenant deux ans et je pense que nous
pouvons dire que et sous le quinquennat
de nicolas sarkozy est sous le
quinquennat de françois hollande
un certain nombre de décisions positives
ont été prises sur ce dossier ont permis
de faire avancer ce dossier
aujourd'hui il nous faut avancer encore
plus vite et vous avez raison de le
rappeler
même la députée je tiens à saluer moi
aussi le travail qui a été accompli par
la commission d enquête parlementaire le
député serge letchimy
la députée évidemment justine bénin qui
à eux deux ont accompagné justement ce
travail sans précédent de vérité avec
des préconisations que nous allons sans
tarder mettre en oeuvre les délais
seront tenus
dès cette fin d'année madame la députée
sur le plan chlordécone 4 il y avait un
certain nombre de précautions de
préconisations pardonnez moi dans les
travaux de la commission denquête la
nomination d'un directeur de projet pour
suivre autant les questions locales que
nationales ça sera fait 2 millions
d'euros madame les députés seront
débloqués pour tester les personnes
prioritaires les publics prioritaires on
pense notamment aux femmes qui
souhaiteraient procréer on pense
également aux exploitants des jardins
jaffa mais on doit également avancé
encore plus vite sur la question de la
reconnaissance des maladies
professionnelles sur lequel je serai
amené à vous réunir pour continuer de
travailler d'avancer sur ce sujet même
est député c'est un sujet grave
je vous remercie pour la tonalité de
votre question ce la douane plus tôt
nous rassemble et nous conduire à
trouver des décisions et des mesures qui
soient aussi précise que possible
et comme vous je regrette la
récupération le recel politiciens
malheureusement parfois de cette
question sur vos territoires aux
antilles car là aussi demain on doit
trouver des solutions pour nos
concitoyens et certaines pas des
problèmes nouveaux
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur rodrigue qu'au point d'eau
merci merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur remise de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères
plusieurs semaines 40 jours précisément
que nasrin sotoudeh a entamé une grève
de la faim
cette avocate iranienne militante des
droits humains détenus depuis 2018 pour
avoir défendu entre autres des femmes
ayant retiré leur voile en public afin
de protester contre cette obligation qui
leur incombent
hier nous apprenions que cette militante
est actuellement entre la vie et la mort
car elles refusent d'abandonner ce qui
lui tient à coeur
faire respecter les droits humains la
crise du coffee de 19 à renforcer sa
détermination mais aussi les disparités
entre détenus
comment cette femme
lauréate du rhône nommé prix sakharov
qui récompense justement celles et ceux
qui luttent chaque jour contre
l'oppression l'injustice et intolérance
pouvait-elle renoncé à défendre ses
propres droits s expriment aujourd'hui
non pas avec des mots dont se laissant
mourir de faim en espérant sans doute
que son action aura un impact plus fort
peut se dire
faut-il en arriver là pour faire
reconnaître son droit à un procès
équitable s dans là le prix à payer pour
oser défendre une parole libre il s'agit
là de savoir ce que nous pouvons faire
pour sauver nasrin sotoudeh mais aussi
fariba adelkhah chercheuse au ceri de
sciences po toujours incarcérée à la
prison d'evin en iran emblématique en
épandant militante et courageuse sa
place n'est pas dans un service de soins
intensifs elle n'est pas non plus
derrière les barreaux pour une
incarcérations injustifiées
sa place est auprès de celles et ceux
qui luttent contre toutes formes de
discriminations pour leur émancipation
la france est choqué et profondément
attristé par cette nouvelle
nous parlementaires avons alerté à
plusieurs reprises sur cette situation
que nous qualifiant d'inacceptable nous
avons un immense respect pour le peuple
iranien et admiration pour le la
civilisation perse le gouvernement
iranien ne tira que bénéfices et
reconnaissance des messages
bienveillants adressé à son peuple à la
france à l'europe et au monde
monsieur le ministre nasrin sotoudeh est
l'une des voix les plus puissants de
l'opposition iranienne rester en retrait
et ne pas agir ne serait de faire que
fragiliser la relation que nous on
continue avec l'iran
quel sens monsieur le ministre les
actions à venir civile car je vous rends
la parole est à monsieur jean yves le
drian ministre de l'europe et des
affaires étrangères
merci monsieur le député coq window de
faire applaudir dans cette enceinte
nasrin sotoudeh et merci mesdames et
messieurs les députés d'être solidaire
de cette mobilisation
en effet cela a été rappelé par le
député oquendo nous sommes très inquiets
sur l'état de santé de nasrin sotoudeh
elle a été condamnée à trente huit ans
de prison pour a fait son métier
d'avocate dans les conditions qui
viennent dette expliqué elle est
désormais hospitalisé en soins intensifs
à l'issue d'une grève de la faim de 40
jours
nous avons attribué le prix
franco-allemand des droits de l'homme
nasrin sotoudeh et nous l'avons désigné
comme membre du conseil pour l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes dans le
cadre de la présidence française du g7
et le présent de la république à chaque
entretien avec les autorités iraniennes
moi même à mon niveau
nous rappelons notre volonté de voir
nasrin sotoudeh libéré et je vous
remercie aussi d'avoir cité
fariba adelkhah fariba adelkhah c'est
notre compatriote lé franco iranienne
elle a été condamné à six ans de prison
elle est détenue depuis plus d'un an en
iran sa condamnation n'est fondée sur
aucun élément sérieux
elle est purement politique et
arbitraire il nous faut aussi nous
mobiliser pour elle et puis globalement
mesdames et messieurs les députés nous
mobiliser sur l'aggravation des
violations des droits de l'homme en iran
en particulier à la suite des
manifestations de novembre 2019 pour ce
faire il faut le faire à la fois
systématiquement au niveau diplomatique
dans chacune des enceintes où nous
sommes amenés à parler
nous parlons de ces cas-là à l'égard de
l'iran et ça va être le cas dans les
jours qui viennent dans le cadre de
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
qui se tiendra en virtuel et c'est aussi
le parlement qui doivent se mobiliser
comme vous le faites aujourd'hui
merci la parole est à monsieur fabien
roussel
monsieur le premier ministre
le japonais bridgestone fermerait son
site de béthune et laisserai 8 163
salariés sur le carreau avec l'angoissé
du chômage les près de la maison les
études des enfants
au final avec les sous traitants c'est
3000 familles concernées la direction
européenne de bridgestone a expliqué
hier que cette décision était due à la
surcapacité de sa production en europe
de l'ordre de 5 millions de pneus par an
mais c'est le groupe lui-même qui a
organisé cette surcapacité en
investissant massivement dans ses usines
en pologne et en hongrie en 2012 avec
une aide de 24 millions d'euros de
l'union européenne
bedzed stone agrandit son site de poznan
et produit 2 millions de pneus
supplémentaires et en 2017 il triple sa
production de pneus en hongrie
ce sont eux qui organisent au sein de
leur propre groupe
une concurrence déloyale entre les
salariés et avec la bénédiction de
l'union européenne pour au final nous
dire que l' usine de béthune serait de
trop comment la france peut-elle parler
de souveraineté de relocalisation et
accepter une telle décision c'est un
scandale industrielle sociale mais aussi
écologique car les pneus bridgestone
viendront désormais par camion de toute
l'europe
il est temps de montrer que notre pays
n'accepte plus ses choix purement
financiers va-t-on enfin dire ici que
les actionnaires quel qu'il soit ne sont
pas tout puissant et qu'une nation c'est
protéger ses citoyens
monsieur le premier ministre les députés
communistes vous demande de faire
pression sur le groupe japonais en
demandant le remboursement des aides
publiques de l'union européenne fait
pression sur le gouvernement japonais
menacer leurs produits qu'ils importent
en france fait respecter notre pays
notre industrie nos salariés obtenez que
le site de béthune ne ferme pas merci
monsieur le député la parole à madame
agnès pannier nash et ministre délégué
chargé de l'industrie merci merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
vous celle croyez bien que je partage
avec vous le choc est le fait que nous
devons accompagner ces 8 163 salariés
c'est 863 familles et l'ensemble des
familles des sous traitants qui sont
concernés par cette annonce
mais je ne crois pas à la fatalité je ne
crois pas qu'il faut justement baisser
les bras et haranguer ici et là sans
chercher des solutions et c'est très
exactement ce que nous faisons d'abord
je veux rappeler que sur le marché du
pneu puisque c'est de cela que vous
parlez
la concurrence est le premier élément de
concurrence qui explique cette situation
de surcapacité j'en suis désolé mais
c'est les exportations asiatiques
ce sont les exportations asiatiques qui
ont pris 20 points de parts de marché en
vingt ans et je crois qu'il faut
s'interroger justement sur la
compétitivité de l'europe par rapport à
ses exportations
et je rappelle que c'est ce gouvernement
et durant cette mandature que nous avons
pris les premières mesures de protection
sur le véhicule lourd que nous sommes en
train de regarder un règlement qui
permet justement de faire la part des
pneus de qualité versus ceux qui le sont
moins et nous verrons si effectivement
cela permet de privilégier des
productions de qualité française ou
européenne
je veux également dire parce que on va
un peu vite en besogne sur l'europe
l'europe c'est 750 milliards d'euros au
service de la relance de l'ensemble de
nos économies c'est une solidarité qui
n'a jamais été vu depuis des années
c'est une construction qui permet aussi
l ensemble des pays peut-être
interdépendants et de se reconstruire
alors monsieur le député roussel la plus
tôt la ministre
la parole est à monsieur guy teissier
ainsi monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre la france a subi de
plein fouet la crise économique qui a
découlé de la pandémie due coville 19
la france s'est dotée d'un plan de
relance pour sauver son économie
je ne peux que saluer certains de vos
mesures néanmoins dans ce plan de
relance je m'étonne de l'absence de
certains secteurs stratégiques comme
celui de la défense
cette filière industrielle d'excellence
regroupant 4000 entreprises travaillant
à la fois pour la défense et pour le
civil soit deux cent mille salariés
seul le spatial militaire bénéficiaires
de votre plan de relance à hauteur
d'environ 50 millions ce qui représente
une goutte d'eau parmi les 100 milliards
annoncés le résultat est que les
industriels du secteur devront se
contenter des promesses budgétaires de
l'actuelle loi de programmation bien
insuffisante au regard de la crise qu'il
traverse
la norges de la commande de 18 rafale
par la grèce pourrait laisser croire que
la situation est moins critique que
d'autres secteurs
et cela il faut il ne s'agit là que
d'une résilience apparente dans son
point de presse du 3 septembre dernier
le chef de la task force de sauvetage du
pays et aider a déclaré si les commandes
militaires ont continué pendant le
confinement
l'activité civil des fournisseurs a
chuté mettant mal leur état santé
globale on a également appris que 92
entreprises la défense dont 80 % de pme
se sont déjà trouvés dans une situation
critique en raison de la crise est liée
aux convives 19 malgré le soutien du
ministère des armées leur situation n'en
reste pas moins fragile
cette omission constitue une erreur à
double titre d'une part et le fragilise
notre capacité opérationnelle ce qui
équivaut à baisser notre garde dans un
contexte géopolitique qui se détériore
et d'autre part est dommageable sur le
plan économique puisque l'industrie de
défense constituent un des secteurs
industriels français sur lequel l'effet
d'entraînement d'un plan de relance sera
le plus efficace en termes d'emplois et
de valeur ajoutée sur notre territoire
monsieur le premier ministre dans ses
réalités comment se fait-il que le
secteur industriel de la défense sur le
grand oublié de ce plan de relance
merci monsieur le député la parole et à
madame geneviève darrieussecq ministre
délégué auprès de la ministre désormais
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député tessier je prie
d'excuser florence parly qui est
actuellement à une audition au sénat
bon mais vous l'avez dit le plan de
relance du ministère des armées c'est la
loi de programmation militaire
je ne peux quand même pas laisser dire
que c'est rien le ministère des armées a
bénéficié en 2018 d'un milliard huit de
plus supplémentaires la loi de
programmation militaire que vous avez
largement voté sur ces bonds 2019 2025
c'est 180 milliards d'investissements
pour ce secteur
je ne peux pas laisser dire que ça ne
correspond pas un vrai plan de relance
landes de relance qui permettra
d'équiper nos hommes et nos femmes en
petit équipement qui permettra bien
entendu de moderniser l'armement ce qui
est nécessaire qui permet de travailler
dans l'innovation pour le futur qui
permet également et je le signale parce
qu'il n'ya pas que les industries de la
défense que nous soutenons c'est bien
sûr toute l'industrie du bâtiment et des
btp avec des investissements en
immobilier qui ont été multiplié par 2
dont je veux dire que nous participons
globalement au maintien de l'emploi et
au développement des industriels de
défense alors vous l'avez dit nous avons
soutenues pendant la crise les
industries de la base industrielle et
technologique de défense avec des
soutiens à l'export des prêts garantis
par l'état est bien entendu nous avons
anticipé certaines commandes pour
l'aéronautique qui était le secteur le
plus fragilisé avec vous le savez 600
millions d'euros 3 mrt t huit
hélicoptères et donc ce plan-là je ne
ferai pas la liste vous la connaissez
mieux que moi ce plan là est
véritablement le plan de relance du
ministère des armées et
de l'état dans ce domaine merci m'a
jamais la parole de monsieur florian
bacheliers merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues la bretagne connaît un certain
nombre de situations préoccupantes les
plans sociaux et les projets de
réorganisation se multiplient et des
milliers de familles aujourd'hui vivent
dans l'angoissé dans le morbihan ce sont
les fonderie de caudan qui sont en
difficulté avec le désengagement
programmé du groupe chronos à morlaix
c'est le changement de stratégie du
groupe air france et l'abandon de la
filiale up qui auraient des conséquences
lourdes à roscoff c'est la brittany
ferries qui paye aujourd'hui le double
prix et du co vide et du break site à
lannion c'est encore nokia qui inquiète
dans cette région qui assumait jusqu'à
présent de mettre la science le progrès
technologique au coeur de sa stratégie
de développement économique
je n'oublie je n'oublie pas non plus les
pme qui ferment et leur cortège de
licenciés qui souffrent en silence face
à cette situation chacun je crois le
reconnaît sur ses bancs l'état a répondu
présent comme jamais avec le plan
d'urgence mais malgré ses efforts
historiques
les bretons sont légitimement inquiet
par l'ampleur des destructions d'emplois
qui se profile
ils savent que tous ces dispositifs sont
par essence temporaire et se pose la
question de la presse mesdames et
messieurs les ministres
à l'heure de la concrétisation sur le
terrain du plan de relance
je souhaite vous interroger sur l'action
du gouvernement dans les secteurs qui
comme l'industrie le transport le
commerce l'agroalimentaire sont
déterminants pour l'emploi mais aussi
pour la souveraineté de la france
ma question est donc double comment le
gouvernement compte il concrètement
concilier le nécessaire investissement
dans l'économie de demain et le soutien
aux secteurs en difficulté
comment pouvons nous renforcer dans les
faits la mobilisation et la coordination
vital de tous les acteurs de la
puissance publique en ce compris élus
régionaux parlementaire préfet et
gouvernement aujourd'hui monsieur le
député espagne héritage et ministre
délégué chargé de l'industrie merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
bacheliers je sais votre engagement sans
faille au service de ce territoire qui
est la haute la bretagne et votre
vigilance exigeantes à l'égard du
gouvernement puisque vous ne manquait
jamais une occasion de nous saisir de
dossiers d'entreprises qu'ils soient
sont en développement soient en
difficulté les théses l'état est déjà
fortement intervenu en bretagne je veux
ici donner quelques chiffres pour les
entreprises autonomes 224 millions
d'euros et pour 70 mille entreprises tpe
au titre du fonds de solidarité 654
millions et plus de 66 millions d'eur
indemnisés pour protéger les compétences
et les emplois vingt-trois mille
entreprises qui ont eu un prêt garanti
par l'état pour 4,4 milliards d'euros 23
mille entreprises qui vous l'imaginez
bien sont des tpe des pme et des eti
il n'y a pas de doute sur la question
nous sommes également mobilisés sur les
ce dossier que vous mentionnez j'en
prendrai deux brittany ferries je crois
que le premier ministre a affirmé très
nettement et sans ambiguïté son
engagement pour soutenir cette
entreprise importante non seulement pour
le trafic transmanche mais également
pour les agriculteurs et nous avons déjà
pris une mesure d'exonération des
charges sociales pour 15 millions
d'euros mais également nous
l'accompagnons dans la durée pour passer
ce cap difficile et vous pouvez compter
sur nous et je pense également à nokia
avec lesquels nous sommes en contact et
qui devrait revenir vers les salariés
début octobre avec nous lisier en béton
de nouvelles propositions sachant que
nous travaillons de près avec les
organisations syndicales
les élus
mais également les autres entreprises
technologiques du territoire ericsson
qualcomm orange et certains services de
l'état
mais au delà de ça c'est effectivement
le plan france relance dont il faut se
saisir sur le territoire national c'est
2400 projets qui ont été déposés
il faut que la bretagne peuvent traîne
sa part nous travaillons avec les
régions milices travaillons avec les
élus la parole est à monsieur loïc
prud'hommes merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre de la santé hier le
docteur maurice raphaël chef du service
des urgences du chu du kremlin bicêtre
depuis plus de dix ans soixante mille
patients par an a démissionné après des
années a alerté sur le manque de moyens
et de personnel à l'hôpital en même
temps votre gouvernement publie un
décret fourbe permettant de supprimer
des postes plus facilement sans avoir
besoin de reclasser les personnels
hospitaliers
mais chaque poste supprimé à l'hôpital
ce sont des vies de plus mise en danger
les services hospitaliers sont donc déjà
complètement surchargé mais les
laboratoires aussi les fils de malades
s'allonge sur les trottoirs de toutes
les grandes villes les délais pour des
résultats de tests sont si longs quand
les eps quand les obtient une fois sorti
d'isolement votre stade stratégie de
test est donc un affichage médiatique
sans aucune efficacité sanitaires de
même vous allez j'ai aussi le protocole
dans les écoles depuis aujourd'hui les
enfants et les jeunes jusqu'au lycée ne
sont plus considérés comme des cas
contactez les enseignants non plus dans
quel but
ne pas fermer les établissements
scolaires pour que les parents
continuent à travailler
quel qu'en soit le coût pour notre santé
à tous le virus circule toujours plus
vite
aidé par votre gestion inconséquente de
la situation sanitaire
je ne reviens pas sur votre gestion de
la situation économique désastreuse
mon collègue adrien captain ans vient de
pointer là aussi l'inefficacité de votre
politique
vos choix dogmatique aveugle et
impuissants à gérer une situation
sanitaire orne hommes sont donc
doublement fautif il démontre que
factuellement vous faites le choix de
l'immunité collective sans l'assumer
les questions seront donc très clair
monsieur le ministre faites-vous le pari
de l'immunité collective
oui ou non qu'allez vous faire quand les
services de réanimation seront de
nouveau saturé dans les prochains jours
et enfin combien de personnes avez vous
décidé de laisser mourir dans votre
scénario de gestion de cette crise
sanitaire
monsieur le député la parole à monsieur
olivier viron ministre des solidarités
et de la santé monsieur le député loïc
prud'hommes je sais pas en deux minutes
si j'ai choisi de répondre aux erreurs
factuelles ou à l'outrance don fait par
nous fera dans votre question
j'ai l'embarras du choix monsieur le
député on va commencer par le décret
dont vous parlez et tient le décret du 3
septembre 2020 pris par mon ministère
qui tire conséquences de la loi
transformation la fonction publique de
et qui dit justement qu'il est
impossible de licencier un salarié dans
la fonction publique hospitalière
lorsque son poste est supprimé
c'est exactement l'inversé à ce que vous
prétendez monsieur débuté lorsque le
poste d'un fonctionnaire dans la
fonction publique hospitalière et
supprimer désormais il doit être
accompagné dans l'emploi et ne peut ne
peut faire l'objet d'un licenciement sec
comme c'était le cas jusqu'à présent
félicitez nous de cette mesure de
protection la fonction publique
hospitalière monsieur le député dans la
même veine et là j'en viens aux
outrances monsieur dépit des évidemment
vous chercher à provoquer c'est votre
droit
vous chercher à provoquer et vous ne
pensez pas ce que vous dites
lorsque vous suggérer l'idée qu'on
serait en train de faire le décompte
morbide des personnes que nous serions
sur le point de laisser mourir faute de
prendre des mesures de gestion
monsieur le député je ne pense pas une
seconde que vous imaginiez crédible ce
que vous êtes en train de dire je vous
le souhaite
non pas pour moi mais je vous le
souhaite pour vous monsieur le député
parce que c'est extrêmement grave que de
l'imaginer ce genre de choses là
en réalité nous avons débattu nous
allons bientôt débattre d'ici quelques
jours
des moyens qui sont conférés au
gouvernement pour pouvoir dans la
période transitoire de sortie l'état
d'urgence sanitaire de prendre toutes
mesures de gestion utile pour sauver des
vies protéger les populations
monsieur le député prud'hommes je ne
doute pas une seconde que cette fois-ci
vous ferez partie de ceux des députés
qui ne nous freinerons pas dans nos
capacités de nous armer pour lutter
contre le virus mais vous rejoindrez
laurent nombreux de la majorité qui nous
a permis à plusieurs occasions de
pouvoir disposer de mesures législatives
exceptionnelle pour protéger les
français messieurs débuté parce que je
suis sûr que vous avez de la suite dans
les idées de ce point de vue là au moins
sachez en tout cas qui n'est pas du tout
question de laisser mourir qui que ce
soit il n'est pas question du tout
d'aller de tendre vers une immunité
collective ça ne marche pas les pays qui
l'ont essayé ont échoué à le faire nous
voulons protéger chaque ville chaque
français vis-à-vis
monsieur meyer habib merci monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
rien à [__] de la shoah j'arrive
déterminé comme adolf dans les années 30
les rentiers juifs fuck à rothschild
après nick on rate qui appelaient à
pendre les blancs voici quelques perles
du rappeur frise corleone 16 millions de
ventes 16 millions mais ce qui est
terrible
monsieur le premier ministre que le mouv
radio jeune du service public diffuse et
fait l'éloge de ce rappeur qui fait
l'apologie du nazisme radio france qui
vient pourtant d'être rappelé à l'ordre
par le csa pour une fête nous accusant
israël de détruire des installations
médicales en quantico villes
palestiniennes
monsieur le premier ministre
l'antisémitisme se banalise dans notre
pays dans les territoires perdus de la
république la haine du juif est devenu
un code culturel son fonds d'islamisme
de théories du complot de racisme
anti-blancs de haine de la france pour
eux est clair les tueurs de toulouse de
charlie du bataclan son doigt héros hier
asie siboni hier parties civiles
victimes de l'hyper cacher caissière de
l'hyper cacher parti depuis en israël
témoigné je cite
j'avais l'habitude dans ma banlieue de
me faire traiter de sale juive et de
faire cracher dessus
c'était il ya cinq ans rien n'a changé
depuis ou plutôt si sara lee me mirek
noël ont été massacrées depuis il y à un
mois david a été rouée de coups dans le
19ème d'antisémitisme tu frappes
insultes je vous ai par des menaces
quotidiennes dont je suis la cible en
tant que député juif
ce matin c'était la photo d'une
kalachnikov oui c'est vrai vous ministre
de l'intérieur et de la justice ont été
très clairs à gauche silence et là ce
qui est venue cette gauche humaniste et
républicaine celle de jaurès blum mendès
france elle se fourvoie aujourd'hui dans
le communautarisme l'islamo gauchisme
l'indigénisme et l'antisionisme ces
mêmes députés de gauche mais aussi
beaucoup de votre majorité qui préfèrent
signer des tribunes contre les accords
de paix israélo arabe
plutôt que de condamner l'apologie d'al
dolphy clair monsieur le premier
ministre je ne suis pas inquiet que pour
les juifs
je suis surtout inquiet pour la france
le futur le député je vais je voudrais
rappeler qu'il s'agit de questions au
gouvernement et qui est toujours un peu
mal aisé de mettre en cause d'autres
collègues qui eux ne pourront pas vous
répondre
la parole tu avales à mme roselyne
bachelot ministre de la culture
[Applaudissements]
le rappeur fruits ce corléonais de son
nom issa lorenzo diakhaté un talent
indéniable et il est absolument
regrettable que ce talent avéré soit mis
au service de propos absolument
inqualifiable racisme antisémitisme et
ce talent donne à pouvoir une influence
tout à fait considérable aux propos
inadmissibles qu'il tient la licra a
justement signalé ces propos également à
la suite de la saisie du délégué
interministériel à la lutte contre le
racisme l'antisémitisme et la haine anti
lgbt
le parquet de paris a ouvert une enquête
nous attendons les résultats de celle-ci
je peux vous dire monsieur le député que
l'ensemble de la communauté nationale et
que l'assemblée nationale condamne
formellement les propos antisémites de
monsieur switched auréole
monsieur donner la parole est à monsieur
aurélien pradié à lui seul merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au ministre des affaires
étrangères et de l'europe
monsieur le ministre nous respectons
dans cet ensemble est votre parole votre
voix est celle de notre diplomatie est
donc la voix de la france
votre signature n'est pas n'importe quel
signature elle engage la france
or le 30 octobre dernier votre signature
a manifestement servi des intérêts
privés
bien plus que l'intérêt national en
novembre le groupe lvmh a fait le choix
de se porter acquéreur de la marque
américaine tiffany hauteur de 13,8
milliards d'euros c'était un choix
d'entreprise dont celle ci était
pleinement libres et dont elle se devait
tout aussi librement d'assumer l'entière
responsabilité
le groupe de luxe s'est depuis ravisé et
dans une lettre que vous avez
personnellement adressé à monsieur
bernard arnault volé au secours de son
conseil d'administration
sans aucun fondement juridique sans
aucun argument solide et en créant un
précédent historique en matière de
diplomatie française cette lettre devait
rester secrète
sauf qu'elle a été rendue publique le
bras de fer entre deux groupes
internationaux auraient dû seulement
agité les milieux d'affaires mais
certainement pas mobilisé la diplomatie
française les intérêts supérieurs de
notre nation et est il menacé
non et même au contraire puisqu'il
s'agissait d'une nouvelle conquête
française sur le marché américain qui au
sommet de l'état vous a passé cette
commande nous apprenons aujourd'hui
comme procès se tiendra le 5 janvier et
votre courrier est versé à la procédure
les tensions commerciales et judiciaire
entre la france et les états unis vont
s'aggraver la protection d'intérêts
privés et de liens privilégiés
aurait-elle dépasser la défense de
l'intérêt général
dans une démocratie nous devons
combattre toutes les tentations
d'instrumentalisation de l'état il
entend de la crédibilité du politique de
la crédibilité d'une crédibilité de la
france et donc de notre souveraineté
monsieur le ministre je vous pose la
question clairement parce qu'elle est
grave
quel intérêt la france at elle servi
dans cette affaire
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
monsieur jean yves le drian ministre
d'europe et des affaires étrangères
monsieur le député vous avez rappelé
brièvement quelle était la situation
internationale et les relations
complexes commercial transatlantique
avec les états unis
je vous rappelle ce que vous savez c'est
que les états unis en représailles à la
taxe français sur les services
numériques ont adopté en juillet 2020
des sanctions tarifaires contre les
exportations françaises et
singulièrement dans le secteur du luxe
ces sanctions ont été suspendues
jusqu'en janvier 2021
nous avons engagé avec l'om c'est des
travaux des négociations pour essayer de
faire en sorte que ces menaces
n'aboutissent pas mais il y à cette date
butoir
dans ce cadre quel est le rôle du
ministre des affaires étrangères en
matière de diplomatie économique
mon rôle fait trois orientations
d'abord il fait part au groupe français
de vocation internationale de la
politique commerciale et
transatlantiques suite gouvernement
c'est mon rôle
deuxièmement mon rôle est de répondre à
leurs interrogations politiques quel que
soit le pays mais singulièrement sur les
états unis
et troisièmement mon rôle et d'indiquer
le cas échéant l'avis du gouvernement
sur une appréciation de nature politique
sur la gestion des grands gérants
certaines nationales à venir et c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai répondu à une
interrogation du groupe lvmh totalement
dans mon rôle monsieur le député merci
monsieur le ministre la parole à madame
claudia roth
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de l'agriculture
j'associe à cette question mes collègues
jean louis bricout et dominique potier
la méthanisation agricole avait à la
base une vertu sociale et écologique
aujourd'hui force est de constater que
son développement s'accompagne de dérive
c'est une source d'inquiétude pour de
nombreux élus ruraux et des
représentants du monde agricole
notamment en bretagne
l'accaparement de terres pour produire
du maïs à vocation énergétique
la disparition de production agricole
notamment laitière insuffisamment
rémunératrice la spéculation foncière
la faction du prix des cultures
fourragères pour l'élevage la
transmission de ces unités de biogaz
valorisé à plusieurs millions d'euros
un mauvais bilan carbone induits par la
transformation de prairies en cultures
de maïs et les nuisances liées au
transport des intrants dont
l'approvisionnement est parfois
supérieur à 50 km des méthaniseurs la
fin doit tirer les leçons des dérives du
système allemand qui a battu et bâtir
une industrie avec de grosses unités et
des cultures dédiées à la méthanisation
agricole
le coût budgétaire pour l'état et le
contribuable à travers des subventions
et le tarif de rachat de l'énergie ne
doit pas permettre des spéculations sur
notre modèle agricole basé sur les
exploitations familiales la crise
sanitaire que nous traversons nous
rappelle que la souveraineté alimentaire
est une exigence
la terre va nourrir les hommes face à ce
constat des leviers doivent être activés
abaisser le seuil des 15% d'intrants
issus de cultures végétales établir des
schémas régionaux de méthanisation
favorisant la micro méthanisation source
de complément de revenu pour les
agriculteurs et les méthanisation en
lien avec les industries
agroalimentaires créer un véritable
dispositif de contrôle par les services
de l'état
réorienter la pâte car il est anormal
que des hectares de maïs destinés à la
méthanisation bénéficient des aides
monsieur le ministre pouvez vous nous
dire quelles mesures concrètes le
gouvernement compte s'y prendre pour
mettre fin à ces dérives
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur julien de
normandie ministre de l'agriculture et
de l'alimentation
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
vous l'avait dit et je ne cesse de le
répéter le principal objectif de mon
action c'est la question de la
souveraineté et de l'indépendance agro
alimentaire de notre pays et cette
souveraineté cette indépendance vous
avez cités votre collègue dominique
potier avec qui j'ai régulièrement
échangé sur ce sujet elle passe par la
maîtrise du sol est essentielle
il ya eu des travaux d'ailleurs trans
partisan qui ont été faits
sur cette question des seuls avec du
côté de la majorité anh laurent speitel
aux côtés de dominique potier par
exemple est aujourd'hui dans ce sujet il
y à une question sur la méthanisation
alors deux éléments de réponse la
première c'est oui il faut établir les
garde-fous vis-à-vis de la méthanisation
est ce que il est normal que demain des
cultures de maïs ne soit faite que pour
faire de la méthanisation
la question que légitimement être opposé
qui plus est dans les secteurs où nous
avons des vrais enjeux en termes d'eau
et d'irrigation et c'est un sujet que
nous dont nous parlons beaucoup avec
barbara pompili et puis deuxième élément
c'est la question des tarifs mais cette
question des tarifs qui est en ce moment
est débattue d'ailleurs elle résulte
d'un point qui pour le coup est positif
c'est qu'on a vu aujourd'hui une
méthanisation qui s'est développé dans
notre pays qui est aussi une alternative
vis-à-vis des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre qui est aussi une alternative
pour avoir un complément de revenu pour
les agriculteurs très important et qui
est aussi une alternative pour cette
économie circulaire et ses circuits
courts et donc il faut à la fois
maîtriser des dérives lorsqu'il y en à
le dire et en même temps accompagné une
filière qui à mes yeux doit être
accompagnée et je défends la
méthanisation et je ne voudrais pas que
ici ou là des dérives viennent jeter
l'opprobe sur la méthanisation
je terminerai mon propos en citant le
rapport parlementaire de jean luc et
fuji sur le sujet de l'énergie dans le
domaine agricole
il y propose des pistes justement pour
développer la méthanisation tout en
limitant les dérives et je crois que là
il y aura des beaux débats dans cet
hémicycle
merci monsieur le ministre la parole
d'un monsieur fabrice bas
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
pourquoi attribuer si facilement les
fréquences 5 g sans contrepartie
pourquoi vous priver de moyens de
pression sur les opérateurs une pression
salutaire pour qu'ils déterminent enfin
le déploiement de la 4g dans notre pays
car le new deal ça marche sur le papier
mais sur le terrain c'est une autre
affaire l'équipement en 4g du réseau
mobile existant a pris beaucoup de
retard vous le savez comme
l'installation des nouveaux pylônes de
téléphonie mobile et finalement pourquoi
enfermer les français d un débat
manichéen pour ou contre la 5g pour
contre le progrès les véhicules
autonomes la téléchirurgie l'agriculture
connecté où l'industrie du futur ça n'a
pas de sens
à moins à moins que vous ne cherchiez
esquivé la question centrale est cette
question centrale c'est l'égalité
l'égalité des chances ou numérique pour
tous les français où qu'ils habitent ou
qu'ils travaillent pour cette france des
territoires qui a bien compris que la
société du tout numérique aggrave les
inégalités
alors monsieur le premier ministre je
vous le demande
4g ou 5 g serons nous encore longtemps
les dindons de la farce au numérique
merci chers collègues la parole et à
monsieur cédric au secrétaire d'état
chargé de la transition numérique des
communications électroniques
merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député brun je vous
remercie de poser cette question parce
que ça me permet en quelque sorte de
mettre en valeur ce qui je pense est une
des réalisations principale de ce
gouvernement
un chiffre mais sur les députés dans les
quinze ans qui ont précédé 2018 dans les
15 années qui ont précédé 2018 notamment
grâce à une majorité à laquelle vous
appartenez ce sont 600 pylônes 6 en
pilonnant 15 ans qui ont été allumés
dans les zones blanches dans les deux
ans qui est à venir grâce au new deal
qui a été négocié par l'arcep par julien
de normandie par n'est ce pas nous
relâcher par mounir mahjoub ici présents
ce seront deux mille pylônes 2000
pylônes en deux ans monsieur le député
autre 600 pilotes en 15 ans dans les
années à venir ce sont dix à douze mille
pylônes qui vont s'allumer partout en
france ce sont 60 à 70 pylônes par
semaine qui s'allument dans les zones
blanches dans votre département
monsieur le député l'ardèche ce sont 38
pylônes qui vont être allumées dans les
deux ans à venir ce sont 38 pilotes dont
quatre qui ont déjà été allumé un la
semaine prochaine aïssa moulenq et donc
monsieur le député je suis un peu tanné
iran c'est à dire que quand je me
contemple
je me désole quand je me compare je me
console n'y a pas un seul pays dans le
monde qui déploie plus vite que nous les
pylônes et dont bien sûr c'est toujours
un satisfaisant
ça vient jamais assez vite pour les
habitants mais jamais personne jamais
aucun pays jamais aucune majorité n'a
fait autant pour lutter contre la
fracture numérique du quotidien
merci monsieur points chez nous
écouterons monsieur brun merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre je
vous remercie pour votre réponse qui
confine à la caricature et qui illustre
la déconnexion de la réalité qui est la
vôtre
parce que oui vous avez raison le new
deal sur le papier ça marche mais pas
sur le terrain
et moi je vous reprendre l'exemple de
mon département l'ardèche sur les 38
nouveaux pylônes 4g qui était prévu dans
le cadre du new deal seulement 5 sont
opérationnels aujourd'hui
5 sur 38 c'est ça la réalité règne alors
que le new deal signé depuis bientôt
trois ans voilà pourquoi nous vous
demandons des actes
voilà pourquoi nous vous demandons une
pression maximale sur vos amis les
opérateurs de téléphonie mobile monsieur
le ministre
les vauréens 30 secondes merci monsieur
le président ça me permet de vous
retourner la question monsieur le député
parce que comment se passe le
déploiement des pylônes mobile sur le
terrain j'ai signé enfin duc à mes
prédécesseurs ont signé 38 sites
donc c'est le quota qui est dévolue à
l'ardèche au total en moyenne ce sera
120 sites par département c'est
maintenant aux collectivités
territoriales parce que nous avons fait
le choix de leur laisser le choix de la
localisation des pylônes c'est un aux
maires aux présidents de conseil
départemental grâce à l'aide du préfet
de déterminer où les pylônes doivent
être installés parce que nous avons fait
le choix de laisser cette malle à aux
collectivités territoriales merci
monsieur le ministre
là s'il vous plaît nous écoutons dans le
calme madame cécile delpiroux qui a la
parole merci monsieur quasi dans ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
du travail de l'emploi et de l'insertion
la crise sanitaire ce double maintenant
d'une crise économique et sociale d'une
ampleur inédite
partout en france des entreprises et
leurs salariés en subissent durement les
conséquences alors que des dizaines de
milliers d'emplois sont menacés
le gouvernement a apporté une réponse à
la hauteur et a jusqu'ici préservé
l'essentiel
nous devons cependant rester vigilant
vigilant à ce que cette crise ne frappe
provoque pas un recul social sans
précédent pour des salariés fragilisés
trop d'entreprises s'attache à restaurer
leurs profits pour satisfaire leurs
actionnaires plutôt que pérenniser
l'activité en france et préserver
l'emploi la semaine dernière bridgestone
annonçait la fermeture de son site de
béthune pourtant à aucun moment elle n'a
eu recours aux outils mis en place par
le gouvernement pour éviter cette
situation depuis le mois de mars le
nombre de plans sociaux se multiplient
au chant nokia
air france au total ce sont 3 145 plan
de sauvegarde de l'emploi qui ont été
initiées par les entreprises de plus de
50 salariés
bien sûr il faut relancer notre économie
sauver le plus d'entreprises possible et
préserver un maximum d'emplois le plan
de relance prévoit d'ailleurs une baisse
massive de la fiscalité pour les
entreprises
mais cela devra nous inciter à plus
d'exigences encore vis-à-vis de ces
dernières n'oublions pas surtout de
protéger les plus fragiles et restons
attentifs
cette crise ne doit pas servir de
prétexte à des abus l'examen du budget
au parlement dans les semaines à venir
doit être l'occasion de renforcer le
soutien aux salariés mis en difficulté
durant cette période pandémique
madame la ministre que compte faire le
gouvernement pour protéger ses salariés
menacés et ceux qui ont perdu leur
emploi
merci chers collègues la parole de
madame elisabeth bornes ministre du
travail de l'emploi et de l'insertion
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
cécile delpiroux par le gouvernement est
pleinement mobilisé pour protéger nos
emplois pour protéger les salariés
protéger nos concitoyens
vous l'avez rappelé ou plus fort de la
crise l'activité partielle à assurer la
rémunération de près de 9 millions de
français
ils étaient 2 5 millions fin juillet est
désormais france relance nous donne des
réponses pour à la fois relancer notre
activité et puis pour protéger dans la
durée nos emplois et nos compétences
moi je note comme vous une hausse des
plans sociaux depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire
alors il faut être clair un certain
nombre de ces plans sociaux étaient en
préparation avant la crise sur ces
dossiers avec bruno le maire avec un
espagnol une hache et nous sommes très
mobilisés pour veiller à la qualité du
dialogue social
des réponses qui permet de faire émerger
et puis pour les entreprises qui font
face à une baisse d'activité du fait de
la crise sanitaire
nous disposons dans le cadre de france
relance d'outils puissants notamment
l'activité partielle de longue durée qui
permet d'éviter les licenciements en
partageant l'activité entre tous les
salariés et en renforçant leurs
compétences grâce à la formation
professionnelle
cet outil les branches sont en train de
s'en saisir trois accords sont signés
plus d'une dizaine est en cours de
discussion 90 entreprises ont d'ores et
déjà signé un accord qui a permis de
sauver des milliers d'emplois dont vous
le voyez le gouvernement est pleinement
mobilisé pour relancer notre économie
pour créer des nouveaux emplois et pour
protéger les salariés qui sont
fragilisés partout dans nos territoires
merci madame la ministre la parole est à
monsieur sébastien jumel deux minutes
pour parler des oubliés de la relance
ses petons j'aurais voulu vous parlé
avec jean paul lecoq du silence
assourdissant d'edouard philippe sur eux
les dresser roanne mais c'est sur le
transmanche que je veux concentrer mon
propos de tous nos quais à dieppe
dunkerque calais le havre caen cherbourg
saint malo et roscoff montre l'exigence
d'un plan de soutien massif au
transmanche percuté de plein fouet par
la crise sanitaire et la 14ème
britannique
je viens de réunir les élus normands sur
la jetée de dieppe pour porter cette
revendication pour la dig dia plus à
vonn vieille d'un siècle et demi
vous le savez les liaisons maritimes
avec l'angleterre sont vitales vitales
pour l'emploi l'emploi français
notamment le pavillon français est en
jeu cinq mille emplois directs et treize
mille cinq cents emplois indirects sont
concernés
vital pour le tourisme lorsqu'on sait
que 1,5 milliard sont réinjectés dans
l'économie par les voyageurs
britanniques après un élargissement des
mesures du plan touristes cet été pour
le transmanche
le premier ministre vient d'annoncer un
peu à larache
pour 2021 le remboursement des
cotisations sociales pour l'année
prochaine mais nous restons aux milliers
de la traversée avec cette annonce
les compagnies toutes les compagnies
toutes les traversées tous les pores
transmanche doivent être assurés du
soutien de l'état pour rester à flot les
lien transmanche ont besoin d'un
engagement dans la durée jusqu'à la
sortie de la crise alors oui je sais les
bretons vous ont bousculé monsieur le
premier ministre que pour brittany
ferries et ils ont fait légitimement
mais quel engagement madame la ministre
de la mer prenez vous pour les autres
compagnies les marins et les employés
des autres compagnies quel engagement
prenez-vous dans la durée il en va de
l'avenir du pavillon français et des
territoires liés au lien transmanche
merci monsieur jumelles la parole comme
à laval et que girardin ministre de la
mer monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
jumelles vous évoquer la situation des
compagnies de ferries transmanche
notamment nous l'avons évoqué ici mardi
dernier dans cet hémicycle effectivement
à l'appel des élus de bretagne mais nous
avions bien relevé à ce moment là que
vous étiez exprimé en rappelant qu'il y
avait aussi la normandie et bien sûr ils
la bretagne à la normandie et ya la
méditerranée et mon objectif est bien de
répondre à l'ensemble des des
transporteurs de passagers c'est ce qu'a
fait le premier ministre mardi dernier
ici dans l'hémicycle en venant compléter
les mesures d'urgence mesures d'urgence
que vous avez rappelé qu'ils ont été des
mesures d'activité partielle ou de prêts
garantis et bien le premier ministre
mardi dernier après ces annonces m'a
demandé de réunir l'ensemble des
transporteurs c'est ce que j'ai fait
avec le cabinet d'elisabeth board bien
sûr avec le cabinet de baptiste de
jean-baptiste lemoyne parce que tourisme
avec le cabinet de jean baptiste
djebbari parce que transport parce que
portent tous ensemble et vous voyez bien
la mobilisation de l'état
nous devions expliquer l'ensemble des
mesures complémentaires ces mesures
complémentaires c'est l'élargissement
des exonérations de charges sociales
pour les marins pour 2021
c'est évalué aujourd'hui à 30 millions
d'euros
des dispositifs spécifiques dédiés à la
formation il faut le rappeler c'est
important le chômage partiel de long
durée mais aussi des mesures spécifiques
au tourisme avec vous le savez le prêt
complémentaire le pge 16 ans et là nous
avons une question et je vais être
vigilantes
c'est sur l'engagement des banques parce
qu il semble effectivement que les
banques on la difficulté à jouer le jeu
avec bruno le maire nous allons regarder
cette difficulté supplémentaire et puis
bien sûr il ya la suite il ya
effectivement la suite et vous avez
raison monsieur le député nous en avons
parlé ensemble
il s'agit bien non seulement des
compagnies de transport de ferries mais
bien sûr de l'aménagement du territoire
des territoires de ressources dans
chaque territoire d'hommes de femmes de
familles entières qui vivent de ces
métiers et bien sûr de l'ensemble de cet
écosystème
eh bien nous serons à leurs côtés j'ai
lancé déjà un travail sur le pavillon
france et nous continuerons sur
l'ensemble des activités maritimes
si le premier mis ses deux présidents
ont décidé qu'il fallait un ministère de
la mer pour être mieux entendues eh bien
je ferai entendre ma voix
merci madame noviny la parole est à
monsieur jean rubrique merci merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de
l'écologie et concerne le développement
anarchique de l'éolien sont nos
territoires
combien de fois faudra-t-il remets ta
question à l'ordre du jour pour qu'enfin
le gouvernement agissent trop c'est trop
c'est le sentiment nos administrés en
thiérache en vermandois et plus
largement dans les hauts de france
la question n'est pas d'être pour ou
contre l'éolien la question est de son
développement harmonieux sur nos
territoires
d'ailleurs qui pourrait s'opposer à
faire de l'électricité avec du vent qui
oserait penser que le territoire ne soit
pas des acteurs de la transition
énergétique trois points posent problème
en premier lieu son modèle économique
certainement trop bien dix ans pour les
opérateurs ce monde elle conduit à des
situations malsaine lobby conflits
d'intérêts village et lui se divise
deuxièmement les lieux d'implantation
on assiste à un phénomène de mitage de
nos territoires
la thiérache c'est une terre de bocage
d'histoire et de combat
dans nos terres sont souillés quand
l'éolien vient confronter nos projets de
territoires culturels ou touristiques
nos concitoyens se sentent méprisés
troisièmement le partage de la fiscalité
aujourd'hui pas de règles mais des
injustices
c'est à ces trois points que doit
répondre le gouvernement les textes et
règlements sont faits pour être corrigé
quand les dérives sont flagrantes
alors quand allez vous nous proposez des
nouveaux outils de zonage qui faisait 2
e
quand allez vous nous proposez un
meilleur partage de la fiscalité
quand allez vous nous proposer un
nouveau modèle économique
madame la ministre la tirage de
vermandois ce n'est pas le monde des
télétubbies c'est la terre du maroilles
fait en sorte qu'elle soit respectée
merci merci chers collègues la parole à
madame barbara pompili ministre la
transition écologique
merci merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député bricout vous savez je
crois qu on partage les mêmes
préoccupations vous et moi on a besoin
du développement de l'éolien parce que
nous avons des objectifs de
diversification du mix électrique pour
atteindre et vous le savez les 40 %
d'électricité renouvelables en 2030
donc on en a besoin on est d'accord on
l'éolien et le photovoltaïque ce sont
aujourd'hui les technologies les plus
matures pour permettre d'atteindre cet
objectif
on en est d'accord on est aussi d'accord
sur le fait qu' il y a un problème
aujourd'hui de développement qui est
déséquilibré sur des territoires alors
il ya des choses qui sont évidentes là
où il n'y a pas de vent c'est un peu
compliqué de mettre de l éolien là où il
y a aussi un certain nombre de
patrimoines naturels remarquables
il faut aussi faire attention et donc
nous devons faire attention à ménager
nos paysages et à respecter nos
objectifs je pense que là dessus on est
d'accord
et puis il s'avère que nous partageons
la même région je suis moi-même et du de
la somme et donc je connais le problème
de développement de l'éolien qui peuvent
parfois être très concentré dans
certains endroits et donner un sentiment
d'encerclement face à ça nous avons mis
en place un groupe de travail sur le
développement harmonieux de l'éolien ce
groupe de travail il réunit les parties
prenantes
donc toutes les parties prenantes je
peux vous dire que les réunions sont
parfois un petit peu musclé mais c'est
comme ça qu'on peut avancer à trouver
des solutions
il va y avoir des solutions qui vont
être proposées sur la fiscalité il va y
avoir des propositions qui vont être
faites et aussi sur le zonage moi je
regrette énormément que les schémas de
développement aient été abandonnées
parce que au moins ça nous donnait de
visibilité ça nous donnait des
perspectives on savait où l'on pouvait
mettre des éoliennes
c'est un vrai problème que l'on ait
supprimé ça et que ceux qui l'ont
supprimé d'ailleurs après nous disent
que le développement est anarchique
quelque part c'est un petit peu rigolo
d'entendre ce genre de choses enfin je
vous rappelle qu'on a une perspective de
développement qui est pas mal puisque
l'allemagne dispose de cinq fois plus
d'éoliennes au kilomètre carré que la
france danemark trois fois plus le
royaume uni deux fois plus donc
travaille ensemble on va y arriver
et encore une mère la ministre
la parole à monsieur à monsieur vous
avez 10 secondes par dont 8 juste juste
dix secondes pour appeler je suis bien
content d'entendre en fin de compte vos
incantations en tant que ministre mais
quelque part on entre en ce moment deux
volets veut de voter la loi asap qui
simplifie encore les démarches et nice
radian6 monsieur le des précieux
christophe blanchet
merci monsieur le président la france
s'ennuie la france s'ennuie car la
france et s'ennuient depuis le 14 mars
avec ses 1600 discothèque toujours sous
fermeture administrative
pourtant les français veulent faire la
fête et de nombreuses seraient privés
sont organisées malgré les risques cela
fait peser sur la société les parmi ses
concitoyens qui veulent vivre des
millions de jeunes ne se retrouve que
dans la clandestinité nocturne pour
décompresser
durant ces soirées interdite tous les
risques sont permis la transmission du
virus sans aucune traçabilité la
surconsommation d'alcool ainsi que de
drogue
dès le mois de juin plus de 150 députés
avaient prédit ce qui allait se passer
cet été
chacun a pu constater sur son territoire
ricks nuisances sonores agression
sexuelle nombreux état d'ébriété et
asseyant de la route
on ne laisse à notre jeunesse que la
transgression pour s'amuser
le gouvernement n'a pas voulu s'appuyer
sur les professionnels de la nuit comme
par le passé pour d'autres politiques de
prévention ses discothèques dont peut
laisser croire qu'elles devront
disparaître
pensez être soutenus économiquement au
bout de six mois d'inactivité totale
elles attendent encore la promesse 07
égal zéro dépense ne semble pas avoir
été tenu monsieur le ministre alain
griset vous êtes mobilisés dès votre
arrivée pour soutenir très rapidement
ces chefs d'entreprise comme les autres
vous avez compris que ces travailleurs
de la nuit trop souvent raillés
participe aussi au développement
économique et à l'attractivité
touristique et culturelle du pays
vendredi
vous avez à nouveau reçu leurs
organisations syndicales
qu'en est il des aides promises cet été
monsieur le ministre nous ne pouvons
cautionner que la transgression soit la
norme ni que notre jeunesse se met en
danger en se réfugiant dans la
clandestinité
alors monsieur le ministre peut-on
laisser la france s'ennuie
merci la parole est à monsieur alain
grise ministre délégué chargé des
petites et moyennes entreprises
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
et député monsieur le député que sur
plancher tout d'abord vous remercier
monsieur le député ainsi que bon nombre
de vos collègues pour votre mobilisation
votre écoute votre mobilisation votre
écoute et le fait que vous m'avez très
rapidement mobilisés sur ce sujet josy
d'ailleurs reçu quasiment quelques jours
après ma nomination j'ai également reçu
à plusieurs reprises les représentants
des discothèques et mes équipes pointent
également travailler régulièrement avec
leurs représentants
naturellement je condamne comme vous
tout ce qui a été organisée de façon
clandestine et qui a d'ailleurs
contribué à propager le virus cet été
concrètement parlant nous avons décidé
en accord et bono le maire est
naturellement sur décision du premier
ministre de pouvoir totalement enlever
du niveau de solidarité niveau 2 toutes
les contraintes qui empêchait l'accès à
ce niveau discothèque trois fois
quinze mille euros et vendredi lorsque
je les ai dit à nouveau reçus nous avons
reconduit le dispositif
donc nous les écoutons nous les
considérons et nous comprenons leurs
difficultés nous allons continuer à les
accompagner
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur philippe meyer merci monsieur
le président
si monsieur le président chers collègues
je tiens tout d'abord à exprimer une
pensée en la mémoire de gilbert meyer
ancien député du haut-rhin et maire de
colmar décédé hier ma question s'adresse
à monsieur le premier ministre monsieur
le premier ministre la semaine dernière
s'est tenue la séance plénière du
parlement européen seule institution de
l'union européenne implantée en france
or celle ci était organisée à bruxelles
et ce pour la sixième fois consécutive
depuis le début de l'année en totale
contradiction avec les traités européens
toutes les précautions sanitaires ont
pourtant été prise à strasbourg pour
accueillir les parlementaires européens
dans les meilleures conditions
bruxelles se trouve également en zone
rouge l'argument sanitaire est donc sans
effet cette situation est très
clairement un mauvais signal et la
question de l'institution parlementaire
à strasbourg est remise en cause
il est clair qu'il s'agit d'une nouvelle
manoeuvre des opposants à strasbourg qui
souhaite que bruxelles supplante la
capitale alsacienne
ce qui est en cause ce n'est pas
l'affaiblissement d'une métropole
française
il ne s'agit pas d'un combat régional il
en va monsieur le premier ministre du
bois politique et diplomatique de la
france
il en va du leadership france est avec
l'allemagne en europe
il en va de la place de la france sur la
scène internationale
comment peut-on ainsi envisager la
réflexion sur la démolition
reconstruction du bâtiment obsolète de
bruxelles à coups de centaines de
millions d'euros sans une réflexion
globale associant le site louise weiss à
strasbourg qui est le lieu de
l'implantation officielle du parlement
la venue du secrétaire d'état aux
affaires européennes clément bonin à
strasbourg le 14 septembre a permis de
montrer une unité forte des
parlementaires et collectivités
territoriales autour de strasbourg
nous attendons à présent monsieur le
premier ministre des paroles fortes et
des actes concrets de votre part tous
les présidents de la république ont
soutenu le parlement à strasbourg
allez-vous agir en ce sens
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur jean yves le drian ministre de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères
monsieur le député philippe peu mais
hier vous avez rappelé la décision prise
par le président sassoli président du
parlement européen de faire tenir la
dernière session plénière du parlement
européen à bruxelles pour des conditions
assez incompréhensible puisque la raison
sanitaire qui étaient évoquées valait
aussi pour bruxelles et que vous avez
rappelé par ailleurs que avec des
collectivités l'état les parlementaires
avaient mobilisé l'ensemble des acteurs
pour qui des protocoles stricts
permettant de sécuriser et les uns et
les autres
le premier ministre jean castex s'en
était ému a interpellé
officiellement les autorités du
parlement européen
je voudrais vous dire cinq choses à cet
instant d'abord nous devons éviter que
les pandémies
ici ou ailleurs à strasbourg à bruxelles
ou ailleurs ne l'affectent le fond que
le fonctionnement régulier des
institutions parce que c'est le symbole
de la continuité de la vie démocratique
et strasbourg c'est un une référence de
la vie démocratique jusqu'à strasbourg
ya pas uniquement le parlement européen
il ya aussi le conseil de l'europe et il
ya aussi la cour européenne des droits
de l'homme tout ça c'est à strasbourg
qui mérite bien le titre de capitale
européenne de la démocratie je sais que
c'est un débat interne mais je me tiens
informé de l'actualité strasbourgeoise
le deuxième
le deuxième point c'est que nous voulons
dire et répéter ici ailleurs qu'il faut
respecter les traités et dans les
traités le siège du parlement européen à
strasbourg
et donc il est essentiel symboliquement
troisièmement que les grandes échéances
parlementaires à venir en particulier
l'adoption du plan de relance du cadre
financier pluriannuel du budget 2021
puis se tenir à strasbourg quatrièmement
le président sa solide devant la
pression des uns et des autres a décidé
de faire en sorte que la prochaine
session plénière du parlement européen
aura lieu à strasbourg
et puis dernier point
il y aura la présidence française au
premier semestre 2022 on fera en sorte
que ça valorise le siège du parlement à
strasbourg
merci monsieur le ministre la parole à
monsieur charles de courson
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
secrétaire d'état chargé du numérique
monsieur le secrétaire d'état le 27 mai
2001 lors du débat sur la déclaration du
gouvernement relatif aux innovations
numériques dans la lutte contre
l'épidémie de kobe de 19
le groupe liberté et territoire s'était
opposée pour deux raisons à ce
dispositif le qualifiant même de pacte
faustien la première raison concerne l
inefficacité de cette application
développée trop tardivement quand à la
détection des personnes ayant été en
contact avec des personnes contaminées
et la seconde raison concernait le
danger pour les libertés publiques du
fait de la centralisation des données et
de la possibilité pour les tiers de
localiser des personnes s'étant
connectés à cette application
cette position de notre groupe a été
confortée par les interrogations du
président de la république qui lors du
dernier conseil de défense sanitaire de
11 septembre 2020 aurait déclaré selon
un hebdomadaire du mercredi je cite soit
en ferme
soit on fait nettement mieux mais
également j'attends pour le conseil des
ministres de mercredi c'est à dire
demain des propositions de fond de
cédric haut
en effet 2 7 millions de personnes ont
téléchargé cette application soit 3 6%
de la population française ce chiffre
n'augmente ans que faure lentement de
plus il semblerait que cette application
est permis d identification de seulement
deux cent cinquante deux personnes à ce
jour soit un chiffre totalement
négligeable au regard du nombre de
personnes ayant été en contact avec des
personnes déclarées contaminés enfin le
coût de cette application n'est pas
négligeable pour les finances publiques
environ 120 milles euros par mois il
semblerait que ça monte à 200 milles par
mois d'après vos déclarations alors
monsieur secrétaire d'état ma question
elle est toute simple
mais elle est radicale le gouvernement
envisage-t-il d'abandonner purement et
simplement l'application pour dire stop
au stop qu'ovide merci chers collègues
la parole à monsieur olivier ferrand
ministre des solidarités de la santé
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le député charles de courson ce
n'est pas stop stop go vide c est plutôt
encore que vides
c'est encore que vides vous avez raison
sur un certain nombre de points
le nombre de télé de personnes qui ont
téléchargé l'application est décevant au
regard de certains de nos voisins vous
auriez pu citer l'exemple allemand
consiste souvent avec 18 millions de
personnes qui ont le télécharger la
balle applications mais quand on regarde
les indicateurs qu'est ce qui nous
intéresse monsieur de courson ce qui
nous intéresse c'est le nombre de cas
positifs déclaré dans l'application
davantage que le nombre de personnes qui
ont téléchargé l'application vous êtes
d'accord avec moi
on ne lutte pas contre une épidémie les
téléchargements bien et c'est là que si
on compare ça devient plus intéressant
si en allemagne du 18 millions de
personnes qui ont téléchargé
l'application
il y eut trois mille sept cents malades
déclarés dans l'application en france
certes nous avons un peu moins de 3
millions de personnes qui ont téléchargé
l'application mais 4900 malades déclarés
dans l'application si on regarde le
résultat
monsieur le député de courson on n'a pas
à rougir ou alors l'ensemble de nos
voisins devraient arrêter ces
applications racing
elles sont utiles monsieur de courson
elles sont utiles stop qu'ovide est
utile pour les personnes qui l'utilisent
et moi j'ai envie de vous dire quand on
constate que le que l'application n'est
pas tout le temps ouverte ou que des
gens ont leurs raisons d'ailleurs parce
que le truc est anonyme
il est gratuit les données sont stockées
en france tout est traité en france
c'est le choix que nous avons fait avec
le ministre en charge du numérique
cedrico a fait il ait eu parfaitement
raison de le faire mais dont acte si
quelqu'un n'a pas envie d'avoir tout le
temps son application
moi je l'invite je l'invite à brancher
elle
mais son application lorsqu'il va aller
justement dans un bar dans un restaurant
lorsqu'il va aller dans une réunion avec
des amis là où la distanciation sociale
et le port du masque n'est pas assurée
c'est ça qui lui permettra d'être
informé avant les autres et monsieur de
courson nous allons renforcer
l'application avec des dispositifs
d'information d'accompagnement des
personnes avec des plateformes
connectées nous contentions numérique a
pas de raison que ça ne marche pas en
france 3 secondes
monsieur le ministre vous persister dans
l'erreur alors puis-je vous permettent
de vous suggérer de méditer le précepte
latin errare humanum est perseverare
diabolicum la parole comme notre avis
passive
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à la ministre chargé du
logement
madame la ministre si la problématique
du logement persiste dans l'hexagone
elle est d'autant plus importante dans
nos territoires ultramarins il nous faut
relever des défis supplémentaires depuis
la crise qu vide dans le plan blanc
outre-mer dieu 2019 2022 le gouvernement
par l'intermédiaire de l'ancien ministre
d outre-mer annick girardin et de julien
de normandie muni chargé de la ville et
du logement a affirmé je cite la
politique du logement en outre mer doit
relever des défis spécifiques cela passe
par la construction de logements neufs
mais aussi par la rénovation et la
réhabilitation du parc existant
ce nouveau plan doit aussi amener le
secteur de la construction en outre-mer
à engager la transition écologique dans
le bâtiment je partage parfaitement
cette vision le dispose le dispositif de
normandie est aussi bien applicable à un
particulier qu'a un bien provenant d'un
programme de rénovation ou de
transformation lancé par un promoteur
pour être éligible le logement doit être
situé dans une des villes définies par
décret à la réunion les seules villes
concernées par ce dispositif sont le
port saint-andré saint joseph et saint
pierre soit uniquement quatre communes
sur 24 le tampon avec ses 80 mille
habitants et la quatrième commune de
l'île sont avenue principale 3 km
environ de trois camps l'imec km environ
et composé de commerces administrations
immeubles et logement mais seuls 4
ces bâtiments datent de moins de 30 ans
madame la ministre
le gouvernement est il prêt à étendre
l'éligibilité du dispositif à toutes les
villes de la réunion
par ce choix le gouvernement pourrait
donner à nos territoires
un nouveau dynamisme cette mesure étant
est attendu par la grande majorité des
acteurs du bâtiment en particulier des
petits artisans
cela pourrait aussi donner du nouveau
souffle aux entreprises du secteur de la
transition écologique et notamment le
photovoltaïque
ainsi les ménages réunionnais durement
touché par la crise bénéficierez de ses
loyers plafonnés je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
madame emmanuelle wargon ministre
délégué chargé du logement
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés madame la députée
nathalie bassir vous avez raison le
logement est une grande cause en
outre-mer autant en outre-mer que dans
l'hexagone et pour le logement c'est à
la fois très important de travailler sur
la construction neuve mais aussi sur la
rénovation sur la réhabilitation de nos
bâtiments et c'est l'engagement du
gouvernement c'est d'ailleurs
l'engagement que nous portons avec
barbara pont piliers avec bruno le maire
dans le plan de relance sur la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
vous m'interrogez plus spécifiquement
sur le dispositif de normandie dans
l'ancien et je sais julien de normandie
à l'origine de cette action
il est à la fois écologique et
économique il est extrêmement vertueux
puisqu'il facilite les travaux dans
l'ancien permettant de remettre sur le
marché des logements locatifs à prix
modérés une fois rénové la question de
la rrq des communes qui sont éligibles
est en fait une question posée aux
communes elles mêmes en effet ça n'est
pas une décision nationale l'état ne
fixe pas de liste de communes éligibles
nous nous remettons à l'initiative
locale
c'est notre vision du travail en
partenariat avec les territoires les
communes qui sont éligibles aux deux
normandie dans l'ancien sont soit celles
qui ont déjà contractualisé dans le
programme action coeur de ville portée
par jacqueline gourault ou celle qui
simplement propose de travailler avec
l'état dans ce qu'on appelle des eaux
vertes et des opérations de
revitalisation territoriales
et au delà des quatre communes que vous
avez cité le port saint-andré saint
joseph et saint pierre moi j'invite la
commune du tampon à se rapprocher de
l'état pour signer cette opération de
revitalisation territoriales qui
permettra de mettre des moyens sur la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments à la
réunion donc je le propose à la commune
détente du tampon et à toutes les
communes de la réunion
merci madame la ministre la parole
tavana monique et michel mercier le
président le seul premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre des solidarités et
de la santé mais tout d'abord permettez
moi de rendre hommage devant la
représentation nationale à l'ensemble
des personnels des ehpad des centres
hospitaliers des forces de sécurité de
secours et tous ceux qui sont en
première ligne depuis de nombreux mois
dans le combat mené contre le
coronavirus ils sont notre fierté
monsieur le ministre depuis plusieurs
semaines la région provence alpes côte
d'azur est classé par les autorités
sanitaires en zone rouge où la
circulation du virus est jugée comme
étant très active
face à cette situation une série de
nouvelles mesures a été mise en place
pour lutter contre l'épidémie de
coronavirus notamment le port du masque
obligatoire dans 27 communes des bouches
du rhône département où le taux
d'incidence est supérieur à 100 cas pour
100000 habitants
par ailleurs afin de protéger les
personnes âgées dans les ehpad
le préfet de région a annoncé le 14
septembre dernier
l'encadrement plus strict des visites
qui sont depuis cette date limité à une
seule visite en chambre et à deux
personnes par jour depuis le mois de
mars dernier les ehpad du pays d'arles
ont dû faire face à une situation
sanitaire exceptionnel par sa gravité
par son ampleur inédite
l'ensemble de leur personnel est
pleinement mobilisée faisant preuve d'un
professionnalisme à toute épreuve pour
apporter les meilleurs soins à nos aînés
ceci sans ménager ses efforts et sans
compter ses heures
monsieur le ministre permettez moi alors
de vous demander quelles sont les
mesures mises en place par le
gouvernement afin de permettre d'une
part au personnel soignant des ehpad au
contact des plus
une érables de continuer à exercer sa
vocation en toute sécurité et d'autre
part quelles sont celles envisagées afin
de permettre aux ehpad d'être de
véritables lieux de vie où les résidents
auraient de nouveau la possibilité de
partager un moment avec celles et ceux
qui leur sont chers dans le plus grand
respect des gestes barrières et des
mesures de protection je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités et de la santé madame la
députée monique à michel merci pour
votre question d'abord vous signaler
qu'il ya 178 cluster en cours
d'investigation en ehpad dans notre pays
chaque jour il y a dix cluster
supplémentaires dans les ehpad malgré
tout l'action vigilante des directions
d'établissement et des soignants et des
familles le prix dans la république
alors à l'heure à laquelle vous
m'interrogez est justement en
déplacement dans un ehpad pour témoigner
de son soutien à la communauté des
professionnels dans le secteur du médico
social
vous avez raison de souligner que les
situations d'isolement ont été très
durement vécu pendant la première vague
notre credo c'est protéger nos aînés
sans les isoler pour cela nous avons une
ligne de crête tout mettre en oeuvre
pour éviter de suspendre les visites les
activités au sein de l'établissement
tout mettre en oeuvre pour éviter d'en
arriver à l'isolément des personnes
âgées en ehpad voir visuellement en
chambre nous prenons des mesures qui
sont adaptés territoire par territoire
en fonction de la situation épidémique
comme pour le reste des mesures de
gestion et nous appelons un effort
vraiment collectif le respect total des
gestes-barrières le port du masque en
toutes circonstances notamment lorsqu'on
est famille et qu'on vient visiter son
aîné c'est fondamental de respecter cela
et de ne pas faire courir de risques à
la personne qu'on visite et à toutes les
personnes qui partagent le même
établissement
le lien avec les familles est
primordiale et nous voulons le maintenir
cela exige cet effort de tous les
instants de tout le monde et puis vous
parler du soutien aux professionnels
dans les ehpad
vous avez aussi raison c'est un point d'
alerte particulier que je suis de très
près avec brigitte bourguignon qui est
ministre délégué à l'autonomie un
dispositif financier incitatif a été mis
en place pour que les libéraux puissent
prêter main forte au personnel dans les
ehpad
et puis j'invite la représentation
nationale puisque m'interroger a relayé
massivement notre appel auprès des
professionnels volontaires pour venir se
rendre disponible pour les ehpad ya une
plateforme internet qui s'appelle
renfort rh point solidarité tirer
sante.gouv.fr on le mettra sur internet
c'est important de pouvoir aider de
participer à cet effort national pour
protéger nos aînés sans les isoler merci
monsieur le ministre de cette adresse
facile à retenir la séance des questions
au gouvernement et terminer la séance
est suspendue